local news it's mostly known for
informative and hard-hitting segments
like this one police say one of the mass
suspects armed with a handgun got out of
his car walked up to the victims window
pointed the gun right at her face and
told her he wanted her purse her money
and her cell phone holy you have
got to hand it to him that is a great
way to make people pay attention to a
story they may not be interested in and
with that in mind our main story tonight
concerns of potential problems in
corporate consolidation of local news so
if you dare change the channel national
cable news gets a lot of attention with
their big budgets and their fancy
graphics packages meanwhile local news
often have to do a lot more with a lot
less the black bear was roaming through
teen American's backyard tina was too
stunned to get a picture but this is
what the bear probably looked like
except real this recreation identifies
how witnesses say the bear escaped into
the wood know what whoever is hiding
behind that tiny bear cutout deserves a
Pulitzer oh sure sure he could have
stood up straight and just walked the
bear across the garden it would have
been exactly as convincing but he didn't
do that he hunched down because he cares
that man is a journalist look it's easy
to make fun but local news fills an
important role finding stories that the
national news is missing this show uses
local news all the time our civil
forfeiture piece used outstanding
reporting from Tennessee's newsChannel
five and our piece on problems with
9-1-1 use great work from Atlanta's
11alive in fact a Pew study last year
found that local news is trusted more
than national news people absolutely
love it so yes when you watch local news
you may see something something silly
but you also may see something great and
there's actually a third option because
in some parts of the country you might
see this I've got a message for certain
students listen up closely snowflake yes
I'm talking to you you the social
justice warrior who wins for trigger
warnings
and safe spaces not grown up enough to
deal with the facts then hunker down in
your room and snapchat the day away with
other social justice warriors college
isn't a babysitting service it's time to
grow up snowflake now that man is Mark
Hyman with one in what I presume is a
series featuring titles like wake up
live Todd cuts much a little beta baby
and knock-knock sheeple it's me truth
with Mark Hyman Holman is a commentator
and former executive at Sinclair
Broadcast Group and Sinclair maybe the
most influential media company that
you've never heard of not only are they
the largest owner of local TV stations
in the country they could soon get even
bigger sinclair will pay about four
billion dollars for tribune media and
it's 42 local stations the combined
companies will create the largest single
group of television stations in the
nation Wow
it is a little disconcerting to learn
that something you've only just heard of
is throwing around four billion dollars
if I finding out that ExxonMobil just
got bought and it was by the little
twerp who plays the new spider-man what
how how's that possible
how does fiber twerp have the resources
to do that I only just found out he
existed now this acquisition still need
regulatory approval but it is widely
assumed that that will happen at which
point
Sinclair's reach could expand
dramatically we did some math and we
found out that when you combine the
most-watched nightly newscasts on
Sinclair and Tribune stations in some of
their largest markets you get an average
total viewership of 2.2 million
households and that is a lot it's more
than any current primetime show on Fox
News including five idiots have the most
intolerable dinner party ever and that
guy from college everyone hated has a
talk show now the suck is Alton and the
Fox News parallels don't stop there
because Sinclair's content tilts
noticeably conservative remember that
snowflake guy Sinclair produces those
segments and sends them to their
affiliates and that in itself is already
unusual as best we can tell no other
major owner of TV stations distributed
own commentary segments to run during
local news
and Highlands opinions hew hard right we
are threatened by a nasty cancer
epidemic it's a danger to our nation it
is political correctness and
multiculturalism words that were once
acceptable and play conversation are no
longer handicapped and are now
off-limits
there is one step that's proven to
dramatically reduce domestic violence
marriage I am now a proud Washington
Redskins fan and the opinion that only
black people can legitimately have an
afro someone should tell that to
American folk singer Art Garfunkel what
are you talking about
as I believe Paul Simon once said have
no need to involve Art Garfunkel in any
of this and I think it Taemin is not see
Claire's only conservative voice just
recently they're hot they hired a man
named Boris Epstein a former Trump
adviser who you may remember from
multiple TV appearances last year where
he made wild claims like this one Barack
Obama wanted 2008 North Carolina due to
illegal voter projects art or its work
where are you getting that from Barack
Obama won in North Carolina because of
voter fraud 5% of voting in North
Carolina made them by people who are
non-citizens who should not have been
voting and sworn North Carolina to mr.
Obama now obviously that is nothing even
resembling a fact the claim he's making
received a pants on fire from PolitiFact
and even if it were true which again it
isn't Obama still would have beat McCain
by 162 electoral votes which raises the
question do Trump surrogates even know
why they are lying or are they driven by
some vague instinct like when a cat sits
inside a box why are you doing that I
have no idea
there's just something inside me that
tells me I should
and yes and yet Epstein is now
Sinclair's chief political analyst and
has a regular segment called bottom line
with Boris let me show you a recent one
concerning a retracted story on CNN the
bottom line is this
CNN along with other cable news networks
is struggling to stick to the facts and
to be impartial and covering politics in
general and this president specifically
oh come on that could not be more pot
calling the kettle black if he said the
bottom line is CNN is a rejected extra
from The Sopranos in a JC Penney's tie
whose voice sounds like Sylvester
Stallone with a mouth full of bees but
but Sinclair doesn't just lean right
with its commentators even its add
brakes sometimes put a thumb on the
scale in 2010
Sinclair's Pittsburgh affiliate called a
30 second Democratic ad off the air
after they received a complaint and
found that some claims in the ad were
unsubstantiated and look that's a good
thing it is good that they were willing
to take a stand to ensure nothing
inaccurate made its way on air although
just a few months later that exact same
station and multiple other Sinclair
outlets and a 25 minute attack ad on
Democrats featuring assertions like this
during his presidential election he
wound up with a record shattering 750
million dollars in his campaign to this
day he refuses to report from whence it
came
one reason might be that some of it
originated from the terrorist group
Hamas oh my God look if you are going to
make up scary donors to the Obama
campaign why stop with Hamas just keep
going he won't say where the money came
from one reason may be that it
originated with this gang of coyotes
that has made billions selling human
babies to other hungrier coyotes and
look if the opinions were confined just
to the commentary or to the ad breaks
that would be one thing but Sinclair can
sometimes dictate the content of your
local newscast as well and in contrast
to Fox News a clearly conservative
outlet way you basically know what
you're getting with Sinclair
they are injecting Foxworthy content
into the mouths of your local news
anchors the two people who you know and
who you trust and who's on-screen
chemistry can usually best be described
as two people and the thing is you may
not realize it's happening because
Sinclair and its Digital new subsidiary
circuit not only produce and send
packages to their stations they even
write scripts that local anchors can use
to introduce the pieces for example
which is this Tuesday night and because
of Sinclair stations all over the
country introduced a story about Michael
Flynn like this did the FBI have a
personal vendetta in pursuing the Russia
investigation of president Trump's
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn did the FBI have a personal
vendetta and pursuing the Russia
investigation of president Trump's
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn did the FBI have a personal
vendetta and pursuing the Russia
investigation of president Trump's
former national security adviser Michael
Flint
did the FBI have a personal vendetta and
pursuing the investigation it could very
well be true yeah but you could say it
could very well be true about anything
are all peanut M&Ms just snake eggs
painted different colors to Fox's walk
on their hind legs when no one is
looking is there really only one awesome
twin who's moving back and forth that
could be human sleep to trick me human
eyes are seeing two of them all of those
things could very well be true and aside
from that one about the Olsen twins
none of them are now the story they were
teasing was that Michael Flynn had
apparently spoken up on behalf of a
former FBI agent and a gender
discrimination suit against the agency
but it is a huge stretch to get from
there to an agency-wide conspiracy to
bring him down
but the problem is there is real power
in hearing your trusted local
newscasters using FBI and personal
vendetta in a sentence if those same
news car
somehow use the words Daniel Stern and
explosive ejaculation in the same
sentence you could never watch home
alone the same way again
and think less content can often not be
optional they regularly send out what
are called must runs segments that
station managers are directed to work
into their broadcasts both Boris Epstein
and Mark Hyman segments are must runs
and so are some new segments in fact let
me give you a taste of a must run story
that ran just a month before last year's
election how can Americans especially
blacks and Latinos in America support
Calibri Clinton it's a surprising
message coming from a black pastor but
evangelical bishop Aubrey shines is
spreading a message of why he believes
Hillary Clinton's Democratic Party isn't
good for black Americans party that gave
this country slavery the KKK Jim Crow
laws whoa whoa whoa hold on huh just
just hold on a second air kiss first
Democrats gave this country slavery it's
a little more complicated than that sure
someone gave me this haircut but I'm
accountable for being comfortable with
it lighting it and keeping it around for
a morally repugnant amount of time look
I knew it you can maybe maybe see why
that could be news in Florida Tampa
pasta makes crazy video but that piece
ran in Columbus El Paso Omaha Syracuse
Seattle Green Bay Tulsa and stations all
over the country and to be fair Sinclair
didn't let all that pastors and Surgeons
go go by completely unchecked they did
have the brief appearance of balance by
bringing in this political scientist who
fact check the video but he was given
far less screen time than the pasta and
the voice-over undercut him at every
turn
Bullock says that shines cherry-picked
is history but if you have the whole
context of history and where these
things are mentioned where they actually
miss peaceless then you would not be
personally persuaded at all
so about that history when it comes to
the KKK historians generally agree it
was created in post-civil war
reconstruction by Democrat and later
Southern Democrats were behind the Jim
Crow laws yes that was the party of the
south and as I mentioned over time those
parties have actually shifted in terms
of what their membership basis I
absolutely loved his frustration and he
tries to explain that now is not 100
years ago you almost expected to say
I'll prove it neither of us are wearing
bowler hats and that woman over there
has a job
all of which supports my theory that as
I've mentioned now is not 100 years ago
and here's the thing the must runs are
not just individual pieces they are also
recurring features like poll questions
which can range from benign to pretty
leading what did you think of today's
call me testimony do you think it was
all about substance or theater do you
think enough is being done to battle
street gangs in the US
do you trust information from unnamed
sources in the Washington Post stories
why are cable news channels airing so
much coverage of the Trump Russia story
so here are the options its bias against
the president for higher ratings or it's
a really important story okay there is a
clear slant to those questions and
answers I can't wait for the inevitable
poll how would you describe the way
Donald Trump looks in athletic wear a
Adonis like me Herculean see striking
from a man of his age or D not my thing
but I'd still hit it so perhaps the most
troubling thing of all is that Sinclair
has a daily must run segment called the
terrorism alert desk that is right they
report on terrorism every single day
whether there is something major to
report on or not
which means that sometimes the updates
contain things like this the company in
charge of security for the Wimbledon
tennis tournament says the ringleader of
the London Bridge attack did apply for a
job now he was not interviewed and no
interview was scheduled he just filled
out in online application an Isis flag
was found hanging in a neighborhood in
New Hampshire it was taken down and
police are looking
and who put it there from the terrorism
alert desk in Washington I'm lindsey
mastis
in other alerts my grandma heard a loud
noise a man with a beard asked me when
the next bus is coming and Iran still
exists from the terrorism alert desk in
Washington I am just about done with
this I look look there is no doubt
that the terror alert desk has also
featured some truly terrifying stories
Isis has carried out a gruesome public
execution in Iraq they slice 19 in half
with a chainsaw
now that caught our attention because it
feels like the sort of thing we'd have
seen reported elsewhere so we try to
track down that story and it originated
with an anonymously sourced report on
something called Iraqi news we weren't
able to find any outlet that it
independently verified it and even when
it was picked up by British tabloids and
Breitbart they were careful to distance
themselves with language like it has
been claimed and reportedly
and I did not know it was possible to
dip beneath the journalistic standards
of Breitbart that's not being too bad a
chef to work at a carnival food cart
look your throat ham is unimaginative
and bland and we cannot have that
where uncle stickies discount ham wagon
look they reported it like it was a fact
and what was perhaps even weirder about
that chainsaw segment was the story that
closed it out and mayor's in 22 French
towns are ignoring a high court's ruling
that says banning bikinis is illegal
more than 30 towns initially outlaw the
swim swimwear worn mostly by Muslim
women from the terrorism alert desk
I'm Michelle Marsh what oh that is
not about terrorism it's just about
Muslims by that definition terrorism is
anything unloose loomed us tonight
Marcia Lally on the cover of GQ Kareem
abdul-jabbar sneezed in an airport and
happy birthday to Fareed Zakaria this
has been your terrorism alert yes
now now to their credit in the face of
all of this some Sinclair stations are
fighting back against their parent
company for instance their station in
Seattle
KOMO has engaged in clever acts of
rebellion like airing lust runs at times
of low viewership in fact they're only
airing of the story about the New
Hampshire Isis flag was at 4:54 a.m. so
is basically only seen by people in
hospital waiting rooms customers at
24-hour 7-eleven and Craig just go to
bed crave get your together and go
to bed but the truth is if you work at a
Sinclair station there is only so much
that you can do and should this Tribune
acquisition go through there are going
to be even more good journalists having
to see their hard work placed alongside
Tara desk nonsense
just as there'll be even more
unsuspecting audience members who'll be
getting a heaping dose of Sinclair's
content possibly without realizing it so
you should find out who owns your local
stations and bear that in mind as you
watch and for any Tribune station that
could soon be taken over we produced a
little video so you can alert your
viewers don't think of it as a must run
think of it more as a probably should
run take a look hello i'm steve
Schirripa from The Sopranos and I'm
probably not the last guy with an accent
we're in a cheap Thai standing in front
of a green screen that you're going to
see on this channel and I'll tell you
what this station could soon be owned by
Sinclair Broadcast Group so you might
see this guy with this
logo or this desk and if you do
just know that wasn't produced by this
station because the people at this
station know that local news should
never be about cheap scaremongering or
advancing a political agenda it should
only be about whether sports I team
investigations and human interest
stories featuring cute animals like this
pops le Fay
look at it some guys keep called pork
chop anyway I've seen sheriffin telling
you if this becomes a Sinclair station
good luck with that
[Applause]